Our next speaker is Thomas Peacock, who's going to talk to us about navigating the
avicapsid secret space using virus-specific protein language models.
Okay, thank you, good morning everyone.
My name is Thomas Peacock, I am an AI research scientist at Lear Therapeutics and yes, today
I will introduce some of the work we've been doing developing virus-specific protein language
models for AAV capsid design.
At Lear, we are aiming to reimagine viral delivery starting with AAV.
So we have developed our multi-modal lab-in-the-loop platform navigator to generate AI optimized
libraries with high impact mutations, not just in a single region, but across the entire
viral surface.
These libraries are validated through a combination of our in vivo tissue screens for tropism
and potency and in vitro assays for immunovasion, with each experiment feeding new data back
into the navigator platform to retrain and refine our models.
Navigator itself is a holistic AI platform for viral vectors.
Some of its core components include our virus-specific DNA models that we use for library generation
our structural analysis suite that we use for rapid capsid assembly and large scale
docking screens and our protein language models that I will talk about throughout the rest
of this talk.
We've already made some exciting progress using our pipeline and even in our early results
we have observed clear improvements in both enrichment and tissue detargeting across our
libraries.
As a brief introduction to protein language models, these are neural networks that map
amino acid sequences into high dimensional vector representations to capture the patterns
that link protein sequence to protein structure and protein function.
To learn these patterns the model is trained on an objective like masked language modeling
where it is required to predict amino acids that have been intentionally hidden in the
input sequence by observing the surrounding sequence context and by iteratively updating
its own weights the aim is to reduce the difference between its predictions and the true sequence.
The real beauty of this strategy is that the model is learning relationships between proteins
using sequence alone.
This allows us to leverage the millions and millions of protein sequences that we have
collected as a scientific community to learn across the full diversity of protein space.
However when it comes to very specific tasks such as AAV engineering this enormous diversity
becomes something of a double-edged sword.
Popular protein language models like ESM2 are generalists.
They are trained on representative sequences across the whole protein universe but they
lack the dense coverage of AAV sequence variation that is important if we want to model for
example tissue specificity or immunovasion.
The plot on the left here shows a sample of the ESM2 training data with the viral sequences
highlighted in pink and then on the right hand side we have subtracted the background protein
families that were shown in purple and supplemented the data with additional publicly available
viral sequences including AAV sequences.
And it's clear I think that not only are the AAV sequences not present in the ESM2 training
data but they also largely fall out of distribution of the training data.
So to address this problem we have retrained the ESM2 architecture using our viral data
section here to create a specialist model that is tailored to AAV engineering tasks.
We have benchmarked our specialist model that we are calling Corsair against the public
protein gym viral data set and we have found that Corsair shown here in green outperforms
ESM2 in pink across all the metrics that we've computed and for all the model sizes that
we have tested.
While it is important for us to validate our models on public benchmarks our main motivation
is to apply them to our own in vivo data sets.
We have refined Corsair on results from tissue experiments that we have done in mice and this
allows us to use Corsair directly to design our new variant libraries.
To apply a protein language model to our own endpoint tasks like tissue troposome or liver
avoidance we need to transfer the learned representation into our AAV predictive setting
and we do that by adapting the pre-trained network that we've previously been talking
about with our new label data sets.
The simplest way to do this is through fine tuning.
This is where we extend the network shown in pink with a task specific head shown here
in green and this time we continue the training but for a regression or classification objective
rather than the masked language modeling objective that we discussed earlier and we
do that using our labeled examples.
When fine tuning there is a key trade off between speed and performance so allowing
all of the weights of the model to update offers us maximum flexibility to adapt to
the new task but it is computationally expensive whereas we can freeze some of these model
weights to make the model faster and lighter but it will limit the ability of the model
to adapt.
We've compared performance when freezing all of the weights, some of the weights and
none of the weights as part of our benchmarking.
We've also compared these models to the Laura fine tuning method shown on the right hand
side here and under Laura we insert small trainable matrices into the model while keeping
the base network frozen and it's these matrices that update through the training process rather
than the full network.
The aim here is essentially to act as a shortcut achieving high performance by keeping the
training fast and memory efficient.
The results of this benchmarking showed that while reducing the number of parameter updates
through freezing does improve training efficiency it generally comes at the cost of performance.
The plot here shows the effect in one of our heart tissue data sets but we see a similar
pattern across tissues, across both classification and regression tasks and across different
model sizes.
In contrast the Laura fine tuning method tends to preserve the performance close to full
fine tuning while significantly reducing training time so as a result this is generally
the approach we have taken for our future model iterations.
When comparing Corsair and ESM2 on our in-house tissue data sets we observe that Corsair improves
performance across tissues.
The radial plot on the right here shows varying spearmint correlations when predicting relative
transduction across one of our recent tissue libraries and this reflects our targeted library
design where in this case we intended to probe the fitness landscape of a localized region
on the capsid surface.
Across the panel we see a meaningful effect size improvement using Corsair which gives
us a more stable foundation for modeling transduction and identifying both high and
low performing candidates.
While the improvement on the previous slide may appear modest I think it's worth highlighting
the effect that this can have in large libraries.
So here is a example, a toy simulation that we ran where we start with an initial pool
of five million variants which is fairly typical of our current pipeline.
If we assume that one percent of those are hits and that we have two models we are comparing,
models A and B that achieve spearmint correlations of 0.50 and 0.52 respectively then when we
screen the variance with those two models and we select the top 40,000 to proceed to
experimental testing we find that model B identifies over 400 additional hits compared
to model A so not an insignificant increase I think for just that small two percent difference
in spearmint correlation.
Alongside refining our models with more complete AAV data sets we are continuing to iterate
on our model design to further improve performance.
One recent example of this is our multi tissue model.
So this builds upon the Corsair architecture but here we are training a single model jointly
across all tissues.
So this not only improves our training efficiency because now we are just training a single model
rather than separate models for every single tissue but it also allows the model to use
cross tissue patterns to hopefully improve its predictive performance.
The plot on the right here again shows the spearmint correlation when predicting relative
transduction but this time for our multi task model compared to our single task models in
green and pink respectively and we found that the current version of our multi task Corsair
model outperforms our single task models on all tissues except for liver and spleen.
To sum up our protein language model module is just one component of the broader navigator
platform for comprehensive modeling of the AAV virus capsid.
It sits alongside our other models and our library generation tools which together enable
the design of variant libraries that we validate in vivo and produce the data that drive the
next generation of models which power our navigator engine.
To conclude I'd like to thank the rest of the team at Lear, a special thank you to Stephen
for his work on the modeling, I'll be here at ASGCT for the rest of the week along with
our co-founders Kilian and Hugh so please do come and find us if you would like to know
more about the work we're doing or if you are interested in potential partnerships or
collaborations.
Enjoy the rest of the conference and thank you very much for listening.
Thank you very much.
There are any questions from the audience?
I have a very naive question.
I think you did mention the Corsair can also be used for immunization.
Have you tried any of that and have you put them to test?
Yes.
We have generated immune data sets and we do train or we refine the model on those data
sets.
We didn't have time to show any of those results today, we have shown them at a previous conference.
We see kind of a similar performance I think so we are not getting like sort of perfect
performance but we are identifying candidates that we can take forward to future screens.
In our most recent immune study we did identify a pool of candidates that had a specific motif
that was quite interesting where the variants that performed well in immunovasion sort of
shared this motif.
Thank you.
I have a lot of questions from the audience now.
Hi, I'm Jason from Sanofi, great talk.
Could you reiterate some more on the training data used for training Corsair specifically
for the AAV variants?
Were they like all different AAV serotypes, were they all like insertions or just like
slightly mutated versions of a specific serotype?
So for the pre-training step which uses the huge number of unannotated sequences, ESM2
uses the UNRF50 data set which essentially clusters protein sequences so you miss out
on a lot of virus sequences that share similar features.
So part of our data set has been just general viruses, both double stranded and single
stranded viruses to keep our data set somewhat diverse rather than just AAV sequences.
We have added all of the AAV wild type serotypes into the data set and then we've really looked
for as much AAV data as we can find so some of the data is, well a lot of the data is
AAV2 and AAV9 just because that's the sort of data that's available.
We are working in AAV9 at the moment so that's sort of fine for us.
How this would translate to other serotypes in the future is kind of an open question
for us.
Hi, thanks for the talk.
I was interested in your plot where you showed that AAV lives in a different part of the
latent space than the other viral sequences.
There was still a lot of structure and I was wondering if that recapitulated what we know
about AAV serotypes, phylogenetic relationships or even like species tropism.
Yes, so I think that the way that you plot this is kind of not misleading but like I
think this was not really the latent space, what we did was we split all the sequences
by camers and then sort of plotted based on frequency of camers here so I think that does
mean that you see this kind of distributed pattern for the AAV where you have a lot of
single mutations that's spreading out the data.
The majority of the ESM2 training data, the viral population is double stranded DNA viruses
so I think this is why it clusters quite heavily in the center and the AAV sort of spreads
out around the sides.
But yes, what we didn't want to do was to run all of this data through ESM2 to plot the
AAV data compared to the ESM2 data because then you've, I mean it's very difficult to
tell whether that, it falls out of distribution or not when doing that.
Hi, Dan Cox, thank you for the talk.
One question, when you said you fine-tuned the model after the mass language modeling
on specific tasks, you were meaning transduction tasks, a series of tasks?
Right, yeah, so we have calculated various different endpoints.
The example I showed here is we take the number of variants that we find in just the virus
before it goes into tissue and then we check the log fold change after we sequenced the
tissue and then compare it relative to wild type.
Would you try it on multiple tissues at once?
So we have done that for the multitask model, we use all the data at once there.
We give the model information about which tissue that data has come from with the idea
being that if it has that small amount of information it might be able to compare sequences
across tissues at the same time.
I haven't tried blindly using all of the data from all the tissues sort of unlabeled
as one big data set.
I think it would be quite interesting to try though.
I see, thank you.
Thank you.
Thank you, Andrew.
Thank you very much.
So, this is the last one.